Marty Johnson:
One of the things you're going to be doing today is creating a mini-farm. Trenton used to have
135,000 people. We're now down to just 82,000 people. So, we've got a bunch of vacant land
Marty Johnson:
around. We have really one supermarket in terms of one market that is over 40,000 square feet.
We have one other grocery store in the city for 82,000 people. Being able to grow
Marty Johnson:
food close to where people are at is very important... very important for places like Trenton.
It's important across the planet.
Krystal Hill:
It's great to get out and sort of see beyond Princeton, even though this is only about 15 minutes
away. You could see where you could be yourself after college, and you can do things like
Krystal Hill:
this and make a huge impact on the community, and I think it's really cool and it's inspiring
at the same time.
Amada Sandoval:
The students here are incredibly focused, and they're really strong supporters of each other
and that tightness -- the warmth in their community -- it's like a big family, and I really admire that
Amada Sandoval:
and kind of envy that, but then I'm glad to be able to be a part of that.
Peter Farrell:
This is planting a seed, as far as I'm concerned. You're planting a seed for future involvement
on behalf of student-athletes later in life. The continuity is extremely important.
Peter Farrell:
Marty has been doing this for 30 years down here in Trenton -- a Princeton student whose project
became a realization here in helping the community out. You don't know which one of these kids will become another Marty Johnson.
Isaac Serwanga:
I mean, the community part was great, but I feel like one of the things I'm going to take from
this was the people aspect. They got to introduce the people who we worked with,
Isaac Serwanga:
and we got to see a lot about what people are doing to better themselves,
so this is just another opportunity for a lot of people to have that second start, have that second...
Isaac Serwanga:
second chance to really get something done. I mean, there are a lot
of people completing GED programs making sure they're getting a high school diploma
Isaac Serwanga:
in order to better themselves, and that's really something that is good to be a part of.
Andrew Dixon:
Yeah, we're working out here with those guys that we met, with those girls we met, shoveling dirt.
That's a great way to connect with these guys.
Laura Martindale:
Well, I think these programs are important because, for one, it helps us to step away from
the school for a minute and realize -- aside from all the books and all the studying --
Laura Martindale:
there are some important things going on in the community and in the state that we're
spending these four years in. And so, being able to remove yourself from that academic
Laura Martindale:
setting and do something that seems valuable in real life to people, I think, is really productive.
Jeff Kampersal:
The Princeton Varsity Club -- just what it stands for -- we try to instill that into our kids,
to know that it's a privilege to play at Princeton, and it's also almost like an obligation to give back,
Jeff Kampersal:
but I don't think they feel obligated. I think they do it on their own.
Bob Surace:
I think it's important for the alumni that were athletes to see the Princeton Varsity Club
does a lot of great things, and we're able to put some practical experience
Bob Surace:
on that and really accomplish some things that the players will remember for a
long time after they're done here.
Meredith Taylor:
Having the help of volunteer groups is extremely important. The ability to bring in young people
and those that are interested and able to help us get this stuff ready is... it's invaluable.
Meredith Taylor:
We couldn't do this without the help of volunteers.